and it is cold outside a dangerous and
deadly polar vortexes sweeping the
coldest air in a generation into the
country's midsection the Upper Midwest
will face temperatures 20 to 40 degrees
lower than normal today wind chills are
as low as negative 65 in parts of
Wisconsin and Minnesota
the storm system dumped 18 inches of
snow in Montana and almost 16 inches in
Michigan Chicago will be colder today
and parts of the Arctic Circle DeMarco
Morgan is among the icicles in
Minneapolis where the high is forecast
to reach this is the high only negative
10 degrees DeMarco
good morning unbelievable right good
morning to you John as well some of the
most dangerous temperatures will be here
in the Midwest in fact governors in both
Wisconsin and Michigan have declared
states of emergencies and it's so cold
here in Minneapolis that public schools
are closed today and tomorrow after day
of whiteout conditions these people
clear it out snow in Kalamazoo Michigan
could be risking their lives if they
stay out too long as the latest winter
storm is bringing with it dangerously
cold temperatures overnight lows in
Minneapolis dipped below negative five
degrees the youth link shelter a place
for homeless young adults added 20
additional beds 23 old Monica Johnson
who has been living on the streets on
and off for six years says this
organization is a lifesaver where would
you be if you weren't here honestly I
don't know I just feel like I'm blessed
the snow and cold means misery on the
roads plows working overtime up and down
the highways and cars struggling to move
it's too much snow it is too much snow
in Wisconsin a dash cam caught the
moment events spun out and crashed into
a guardrail getting around in the air
wasn't any easier at Mitchell
International Airport in Milwaukee the
weather grounded people in planes trying
to take off we're gonna run the plows
down the runway one more time and
it would be about ten minutes and then
they said it turned to freezing rain
they had to turn around Chicago's O'Hare
Airport saw more than 1200 canceled
flights Monday with six inches of snow
public schools are already closed for
tomorrow the forecast over the next
couple days there could break up 34 year
olds record from 1985 when the low was
negative 20 while the snow may be ending
the cold is just starting it has nothing
to play what experts have some advice
for you when it comes to staying warm if
you have furniture in your home and it's
blocking some of the vents you want to
move it so the heat can distribute
properly throughout your home and also
keep your faucets to dripping so your
pipes won't freeze over so I just play
it safe and if you don't have to come
outside the best advice is to stay
inside Nora
I know DeMarco thank you for your
reporting